[Music]
thursday edition of pftot where we talk
about the things we didn't have time to
get to
during the program because chris and i
were having a knockdown drag out
over the nfl's outside advisory
committee who will be providing input to
the commissioner on covet 19 issues we
didn't get to the other
covet 19 developments from wednesday's
press conference at the nfl held let me
mention this chris
before anything else uh they mentioned
that
obviously the positivity rate is very
low
for the kobe 19 test but they are
adopting the cdc guidelines if someone
has a proven positive
for covet 19 they're not going to be
tested for 90 days because the cdc has
concluded that the antibodies last for
at least
three months so if you've had it you
don't get tested for three months it's
one less person who's got to have that
you know that that alien probe stuck up
their nose every day or however often
it's going to be
you get a three-month dispensation if
you've had it and that gets back to the
point that i've had
teams make to me to explain the
positivity rate being so low so far
could be a lot of these guys already had
it they have the antibodies
and that's why there's so many who are
negative because they've had it
and now it's just a matter of time of
when the antibodies go away and they can
maybe get it again yeah it's really
interesting it
it is and you know it's it's it's good
to hear but you're right it's it's one
you know less thing for that guy to have
to worry about walking into the facility
or whatever that may be
but uh we're gaining more and more
knowledge of that and again
i know we've talked about it a lot but
it just seems like the nfl and everybody
is in the right place with this whole
thing right now and everybody is doing
and taking the the proper steps and
measures and
uh i'm i'm at the point now where i'm
going
like it's been so many days of optimism
right how you always used to go it was a
pessimistic day it's often
like it's been so many days of optimism
now it's like
i've stopped thinking about oh will
there be a season there's gonna be a
season
if now it's like all right are we gonna
get you know all 16 games in for every
team or are we gonna have a handful
of teams that miss a few games but to me
the way it's shaping up
i don't think it's going to be much
worse than that at least i'm hopeful i'm
keeping the fingers crossed
i just i i think they're going to get
all the games in yeah i still
look it's fine that they have a
mechanism in place to consider
competitive issues and decide whether to
postpone games cancel games whatever
i still think that football the ultimate
next man up sport
if you got 46 guys who can dress they go
play
period it's on you to make sure the
virus stays out of your building
it's on you to make sure you've got your
roster constructed in a way that you can
withstand these issues
it's on you nobody else and we'll see
you on sunday they never cancel games
because too many guys are injured from
the other team that never happens
it's next man up even if you're going
into a meet grinder against the best
team in the nfl
and you're bringing a bunch of backups
you still go and you play
when they play in the postseason will
there be a bubble where
all of the playoff teams will be on
lockdown either in one
place in their own cities troy vincent
the nfl's executive vp of football
operations addressed that question
yesterday and he said
that sean payton member of the
competition committee has brought that
up
that possibility of doing a bubble in
the postseason
look they can't require guys to stay
away from their families without an
agreement by the nfl pa and they surely
don't want to do that especially when it
can be done on a voluntary basis yeah
and i think chris is a practical matter
as you're getting closer and closer to
the brass ring
and the season that remains is getting
shorter and shorter
right it's easier to say hey honey i'm
going away for a few weeks i'm going
away until we lose
i may bring home a super bowl ring so
when you get to january
i think everybody on the team you're
crazy if you don't
opt in to a hotel arrangement at that
point
and tell your family i i have to do
everything i can
to keep this virus out of the team
because if we get
too many guys sick for the wrong game
we're done yeah no i
i mean i i think it's a great idea it's
a brilliant idea i mean
it really is it's what should be done
you know and you're right i mean we know
that
there had to be some deal struck or
whatever but
you know if all nfl teams just agreed to
do it
you know and then let's just say the
kansas city chiefs right okay
i mean if mahomes and kelsey and tyree
kill
and frank clark and chris jones i'll go
stay in the hotel
trust me the other 47 guys are going to
go stay in the hotel too because they're
going to realize wait wait
our stars our best players so that'll be
easy to do even if the rule isn't
in place i do think and to your point
you're right you know you can see the
finish line
you know we might be done next week at
the very worst hunting we're done you
know four weeks from now
you know we can we can survive and plus
you get extra money for each playoff win
you get
i mean it can be game-changing type
money for some of these guys so it's
really good
and then the last aspect of the is this
to me mike
like we've made it this far man
i don't i don't want us to get to the
super bowl and it'd be kansas city
versus seattle and russell wilson and
patrick mahomes can't play
i mean that'll ruin everything i mean it
will ruin it
like i would literally go well can we
find two other teams to play
i don't want to watch these two now i
don't i don't want to see it i don't
care
you know so they have to ensure that the
best product is on the field here for
that home stretch
and the most important time of the year
and that's why i would be in favor of
that playoff bubble
here's the reality when december rolls
around i'm going to be far less worried
about the contenders
than i am about the teams that are out
of contention and are just
playing out the string those are the
teams
that are more likely to lose focus and
invite an outbreak
and not continue to do everything they
have to do to stay
on the right side of the coronavirus and
the ultimate incentive is
you still get your game checks if you
play the games even if the games aren't
relevant to anything even if you've been
mathematically eliminated it's another
situation where that seventh playoff
spot is going to come in handy
because i think teams will be alive more
teams will be alive
much deeper into december and it's going
to be a small handful of teams
they're just like ah screw it that's
when the coach needs to explain
to the players you say i'll screw it now
you may be saying i'll screw it to your
last two game checks
because if we lose games you lose money
that's the deal that they did
between the nfl and the nflpa so i don't
think they're going to need a playoff
bubble
i think the teams that get there number
one will be the teams that have mastered
it so far
and number two they're gonna be the
teams less likely to lose that laser
focus on staying healthy
when the single elimination process
unfolds all right when the games are
played this year and this is all very
vague at this point this was a
shefty tweet yesterday source
nfl is now considering a league-wide
policy that would enable fan sound to be
heard in stadiums
now look i don't know whether that's
like they've got the apps where you can
you can cheer at home and it comes up on
on whatever screens they put where the
seats would be
or how you do it this is a slippery
slope
if you start going down the rabbit hole
of how much sound
someone is going to be piping in and
someone pointed out yesterday maybe the
falcons were ahead of their time chris
yeah you can't let it be deafening in
one place
and not in another how do you have
consistency with that i think that's the
risk
and if it's anything more than just
background noise if it's real noise that
affects what they hear on the field
that's something the nfl has to be very
very careful about yeah i
you know it's it's i'm going to be
interested to see their approach to
the sound and the look of the game here
with you know no fans or very limited
fans in certain stadiums and all that
you know i mean one i would hope that if
this rule is set in place
to where yeah you can pump crowd noise
into the speakers and all that
that the nfl would have somebody at all
16
sites that day to go wait we're going to
watch the decibel levels here you go
this is the volume this is as loud as
you're allowed to go you go
past this you get fined whatever that
may be there they have to have somebody
there to watch over that
but i i don't know mike i mean i kind of
want to see at first
no fans i mean we talked about it a
little yesterday where
could be a lot of cool aspects of no
fans and no crowd noise you know yeah
there's a microphone things we're going
to get to hear
but just the way the game's played all
of that you know you pump in crowd noise
again that's gonna be it's gonna lead to
not that it's bad just normal football
again you know the road team's gonna
have to deal with crowd noise and signal
and do all those things
where you know just as a pure fan i kind
of want to see no crowd noise at least
at first just to see what it looks like
and how it goes
it's just odd to think that a league
that once made it a penalty when the
home
team was too loud remember those days
yeah your dad was playing back in those
days when they had to warn the crowd to
shut up
right and if they didn't they were going
to give five yards to their team how
ridic
who in the hell came up with that and
where were all the other
sane reasonable adults who would have
said what the hell are you talking about
johnny we're not going to do that we
want these people to embrace the game we
want them to be excited anyway
now they're talking about this
possibility of pumping in crowd noise
i want to know more about it i don't
like it i'm in the john madden camp he
counseled fred goodell the executive
producer of sunday night football
months ago to embrace the ambient sounds
yeah you're going to hear
things that you never would have heard
before embrace it the problem is you
you're going to hear
things you never heard before which
could be a problem on an fcc regulated
network
but i i i don't need artificial let's
embrace
everything about this reality this is
football in empty stadiums or largely
empty stadiums it's fine it's still
football it's like pizza no matter how
bad it is
it's still pizza let me enjoy my pizza
and if it happens to not have mushrooms
tonight
i can deal without the mushrooms i i i'm
with you
i really do i want to see that i want to
hear the checks at the line of scrimmage
i want to be able to hear some trash
talk and things like that
i'm actually less concerned with the
audio
and more concerned with the visual just
i'm i'm excited to see
what the networks come up with how
they're going to shoot the game because
it is going to be weird you know and
it's still weird if you watch baseball
right now
when they have certain shots and yeah
you see the first five rows in the
background and it's empty it ain't that
cool looking
as to the approach of the nba where it's
really freaking cool looking
they're zoomed in on the court and you
can see that digital wall of the fans
there and they've made it look or feel
normal that way
so uh that that's where i'm also
intrigued by this just to see if there's
any added elements here that the
the tv state networks will come up with
and if the nfl tries to make something
you know be put in place for how it
looks uh on a weekly basis
well remember chris there are going to
be tarps on the first eight rows of
every state yeah and
for night games for the nbc games or
games in a dome
stadium the lighting can be done in a
way where
you don't even see the empty seats cool
so i think
i think that will be a feature for the
games that we have on nbc i don't know
that but i
i think that that that makes sense you
can you can turn the lighting down you
can focus more lighting on the field
and and and people just won't notice
because i remember when
sports first returned it was the
bundesliga german soccer league
and it was jarring when you'd get the
shot of that
wall of emptiness of that wall of
nothing and it will look different in
some stadiums than other heinz field in
pittsburgh
it is glaring there aren't going to be a
damn thing you can do to not get people
to notice
the sea of bright yellow seats
it is horrible the superdome now i think
the seats still look this way i haven't
seen a shot of an empty superdome
in a while but remember how like it was
yeah
opposite colors still that way i think
they changed
i want to say with the last remodeling
job it was changed but i'm not sure
about that
it never looked empty when it was empty
because of that right so
you know they're going to come up with
something and at the end of the day it's
still football and we're going to be
happy
that there's football especially with
two major college conferences not
playing this year and
the other three in an experimental phase
at best even if they won't admit that
we know the nfl is going to play we know
the nfl is going to be there they're
determined to do it
they've done well so far with the virus
it's a testament to what the coaches
have been able to do
as i said the other day if the country
was led by football coaches
we'd have kicked this thing's ass a
while ago because they are
very results-oriented they are very
practical
what does it take to get us to where we
want to be okay that's what it takes
let's do it if that's going to lead us
to where we want to be let's do it
and they've done it and congratulations
to the nfl and its head coaches for
getting the nfl to where it is but i
don't want to jinx anything
there's still plenty of work to be done
when it comes to the actual games itself
chris on the field significant
restrictions
on who can and can't be present
yesterday the headline no cheerleaders
no mascots we wrote last night based
upon the nfl's game day protocol
as negotiated with the nfl pa no
sideline reporters
network local radio national radio no
pregame tv
not that we were going to be at any
games anyway but if we were chris
we're not going to be down on the
sideline nobody's going to be on the
sideline
from any of the networks or any of the
tv stations before the game
look it's smart you're doing everything
you can yeah to reduce the opportunities
that somebody's going to walk into that
stadium
with the virus shedding the virus and
sparking an outbreak
why would you have any other approach i
know that there are going to be people
who are upset about it
but for the most part football's still
football
and if you're doing what you can to
ensure there won't be an outbreak and
the full football season can be played i
got no problem with it at all yeah
me either i mean we don't need the
tentacles of the cheerleaders lives
and the mascots lives you know
possibly ruining our nfl 2020 season and
that's no disrespect to them i love when
they're there and you know yeah it's
they're amazing part of the game too um
but
yeah it's just not worth it this year to
to what you're saying it's really not
and i certainly
will be fine watching the game if it's
the bears and not seeing the bear mascot
i'll somehow i'll survive that
one i really will but who is who's your
favorite mascot like
i'm in all seriousness so who's your
favorite out there
steely mcbeam is he still around just
because it's so ridiculous the steelers
mascot did they get rid of him
think daley mcbeam still survives the
big
giant jay leno yes chin guy
oh what's the hard hat right yeah daily
mcbeans billy stealing
actually actually my all-time favorite
was the old viking mascot ragnar who
would drive a motorcycle
chopper right onto the field yeah they
they got rid of him a few years ago they
have the guy now victor the viking who
actually follows the pft account on
twitter i don't want to disrespect
victor
but uh give me the real viking give me
ragnar you when you have
a team that is based upon actual humans
like vikings and steelers right
cowboys you don't need some big
cartoonish mascot
yeah just do that for the animals yeah
that's my thought well yeah i get that
i'm with i'm with you there uh i you
know i'll miss jackson deville
you know that's who i'll really miss
this year yeah sure you will you know
he's one of my favorites he likes to uh
you know
crap on you from time to time on social
media i was from seven years ago
i love it hey mike at pro football talk
i can keep busting you
up all night but i got important things
to do like
cleaning my litter box now go copy and
paste
where to go jackson deville you said
what i've always wanted to say you the
man
yeah thanks that was seven years ago
so and chris and matt casey so
we don't care enjoy your weekend
thanks you got a podcast today got a
podcast today going to be doing that
um big phil i think is going to be on uh
but yeah we're going to hit a number of
different topics today on chris m's
unbutton
when i heard big and i heard i didn't
know what was going to follow it thank
you for saying phil
instead of what you otherwise always say
uh all right well we'll check out chris
sims on button later today
check out pftpm from yesterday the jason
wright
interview and we didn't mention during
the show today pftpm
becomes part of the peacock lineup in
september wow 6 p.m to 7 p.m eastern
every week wow uh i don't i don't know i
don't know how i feel about two in the
morning and one at night i'm gonna find
out i'm gonna find out soon
i'd rather do three in a row but i'll i
this
you know what there's value in having
something at the end of the day
after everything that's happened think
about all the stuff that goes on
throughout the course of an afternoon
that you otherwise don't get a chance to
talk about until the next morning so
there's gonna be plenty to do on pftpm
i'm looking forward to it it's gonna be
a lot of fun it's gonna be a full day on
peacock 12 hours on peacock
7 a.m to 7 00 p.m pft live dan patrick
show
rich eisen show brother from another
with michael hawley and michael smith
and then pft p.m to
wrap up the day all on peacock that'll
be in september
the first big chunk of it starts on
monday we'll be on pft live coming
monday
this is it next time you're on the show
chris we're on peacock so we need to
make sure everybody knows
where to get it how to get it how to
consume it i'm looking forward to it i
am too it's cool i mean it's the new age
this is the way the world's going so
just everybody's gotta get used to it
and buy in and check us out on peacock
all right uh everybody have a great day
chris have a great weekend
we'll see everyone else friday morning
on pft live see ya
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports